möchte ich in diesem vortrag den begriff
des geistes ins zentrum stellen der
geist begriff ist ja sehr sehr
problematisch gerade auch das deutsche
wort geist im verhältnis zum englischen
wort meint hat eine ganz andere
bedeutung spektrum und darum soll es
heute gehen in meinem vortrag der
vortrag hat sechs teile ich wird erst
auf die ambivalenz des geistes geist
begriffs oder auch des geistes selbst
eingehen dann möchte ich mit kant
beginnen und argumentieren dass er einen
unkritischen begriff des geistes hat und
kritisch meine ich jetzt nicht im
negativen sinn ist ein begriff des
geistes der nicht in seiner kritischen
philosophie angelegt ist aber dennoch
sehr aufschlussreich ist dann werde ich
kurz auf jacobis kritik der
geisteswissenschaft eingehen jacobi wird
nämlich argumentieren dass es gar keine
wissenschaft des geistes geben kann und
begrifflichen gründen
viertens werde ich kurz was zu hegels
wissenschaft des geistes sagen nur ganz
kurz wir hatten ja jetzt schon im
vorherigen vortrag dazu auch was gehört
dann werde ich mich vor allem auf
humboldts begriff des geistes
konzentrieren und von einer
disziplinierung des keims zu sprechen
ist alles sehr interessant rowohlt hat
einen kleinen fragment sehr sehr
aufschlussreiche äußerungen über den
geist getätigt und ganz zum schluss
möchte ich einfach mal systematisch
fragen warum lohnt es sich überhaupt den
begriff des geistes zu verwenden
im gegensatz zum beispiel zum englischen
meint warum sollten wir daran vielleicht
festhalten was bringt uns dieser begriff
ich beginne mit dem ersten punkt so
ambivalenz des geistes was ist
eigentlich geist max scheler hat gesagt
und zwar sehr treffend selten ist mit
einem worte so viel unfug getrieben
worden einem worte bei dem sich nur
wenige etwas bestimmtes denken also mit
geist ist alles oder auch nichts erklärt
man muss zumindest aufpassen denke ich
wenn man diesen begriff verwendet er
klingt sehr schön hat aber die tendenz
zu verdunkeln und die frage setzt die
wie können wir aus dem geist begriff
etwas bestimmtes gewinnen wie fern kann
der geist griff eine analytische
kategorie sei mit der wir wirklich
erkenntnis gewinnen können
ich gehe zurück auf die bedeutung des
geistes hebräischen bibel das ist nicht
unwichtig ist es in der hebräischen
bibel ruhe und hier sieht man schon
diese ambivalenz die strukturelle
ambivalenz des geistes ganz begriffs
ursprünglich wind aber auch hier in der
ambivalenz von erhaltung und zerstörung
von leben also diese dopplung zeichnet
sich hier schon vor zwei beispiele
einmal ausrichter da kam der geist des
herrn lra donau über samson und sams und
er ist in löwen mit bloßen händen als
würde er ein böckchen zerreißen
also hier hat was ekstatisches etwas was
den samson in eine ganz besondere stärke
situation bringt aber es hat auch was
unheimliches es hat was ekstatisch und
diese ekstatische wird auch in ihrem
buch samuel sehr deutlich den kennen sie
alle den spruch ist eine redewendung
geworden da kam gottes geist über die
boten sounds und auch sie gebärdeten
sich wie propheten
also was ist jetzt hier los also extra
ekstase das ist so ein bisschen diese
bedeutung des geistes und hebräische
bibel und ich möchte dafür argumentieren
dass auch im deutschen wort geist diese
ursprüngliche bedeutung noch etwas
angelegt ist in der christlichen bibel
politische theologie der herr ist der
geist wo aber der geist des herrn ist da
ist freiheit
er wird eine der geist verklärt könnte
man sagen und sehr schön finde ich auch
diese doppelung des geistes im
naturalien wie auch im geistigen sinne
diese vergeistigung des geistes in dem
lokal ischen doppel werk in der
apostelgeschichte erst mal vor und es
geschah plötzlich ein brausen vom himmel
wie von einem gewaltigen wind und
erfüllte das ganze haus in dem sie saßen
und es erschien in zungen zerteilt von
wie von feuer und er setzte sich auf
einen jeden von ihnen und sie wurden
alle erfüllt von dem heiligen geist und
fingen an zu predigen in anderen
sprachen wie der geist ihnen gab
auszusprechen also hier haben wir dieses
brausen vom himmel da scheint mir dieses
loch im ursprünglichen sinne noch
angelegt zu sein dann aber hier der
billige geist erfüllt und der ebene
ermöglicht artikulation zu verbreiten
über die ganze will also dieses
kommunikativ für die kommunikative
dimension des geistes sich in der
postgeschichte in einer koexistenz das
jetzt als hintergrund in der bibel dann
glaube ich dass das wort geistiger ist
begriff diese diese spezifität hat
sowohl allgemeine phänomene zu
bezeichnen wie zb das charakteristikum
einer bestimmten sprache einer
historischen epoche nation oder religion
hege hat die schrift verfasste geist des
christentums das sind eher allgemeine
phänomene geschichtlich inter subjektiv
aber eben auch subjektive individuelle
phänomene betrifft bezeichnet das wort
geist wie zum beispiel intelligenz sinn
verstand witz dass geistreich sein also
diese doppelung von allgemeinheit und
individualität scheint mir für das
deutsche wort geist ganz spezifisch zu
sein
im griechischen wenn man jetzt mal alle
bedeutungen auf liste des wortes in
griechischen altgriechischen dann ist es
mal locker neumann timos diamond sich
also mindestens das mag noch mehr geben
also das ist ein ganzes ganzes spektrum
und das deutsche wort geist umfasst die
eben alle und ich glaube dass deswegen
ist ein sehr wichtiges wort ist was wir
durchaus beibehalten sollten was wir
aber durchaus kritisch klären müssen
dazu soll jetzt meinen vortrag ein
bisschen beitragen dann kann man sich
fangen ja wie es jetzt ist geist meint
sollten wir auf den begriff geist
verzichten ich glaube wie gesagt nicht
aber es gibt die tendenz und es gibt ein
neues buch
der geist der tiere ich hatte jetzt in
diesem semester seminar darüber gegeben
und meine teilnehmerinnen und teilnehmer
waren erst meditiert wieso sollten den
tieren ein geist haben das doch nichts
geistiges geister tiere was ist hier
damit gemeint ja offensichtlich eben
mentale phänomene wie denken
selbstbewusst sein phänomenales
bewusstsein internationalität sprache
begriffe qualia usw
ich glaube aber nicht dass diese akte
oder phänomene des mentalen die durch
den englisch das englische wort meint
bezeichnet sind das die wirklich den
deutschen ganz begriffen das deutsche
wort geist wirklich ab
decken können und zwar deswegen weil sie
eben die mir scheint nur individuelle
phänomene bezeichnen nicht dieses
allgemeine auch betreffen können das
deutsche wort geist bezeichnet nicht nur
erst personale phänomene wie es meint zu
tun scheint wie mir scheint sondern eben
auch dritt personal zugänglich die
geistiges kann sich objektivieren und
manifestieren tritt aus der bloße
subjektivität heraus etwa dann wenn sich
ideen den kunstwerken niederschlagen die
sinnlich sei es akustische oder visuelle
wahrgenommen rezipiert und intellektuell
beurteilt werden können als erste person
und dritte person scheint im geist
begriff umfasst zu sein
das historische wörterbuch der
philosophie schreibt zum begriff des
geistes wie ich finde es ja treffen
zitat gerade weil der begriff geist mit
zahlreichen anderen grundbegriffen der
philosophie verknüpft ist kann es nicht
das ziel der folgenden
begriffsgeschichte von geist sein
die geschichte des geistes auf einen
begriff zu bringen es geht vielmehr
darum sie in ihrer fülle vielfalt und in
der wenigstens mitunter sichtbar und
konsequenz ihrer entfaltung dem
verstehen zu vergegenwärtigen
ich glaube durchaus dass man diese
einheit des geistes demonstrieren kann
also es hat sicherlich eine ganze
bandbreite von bedeutung aber wie mir
scheint es gibt ja auch eine einheit und
diese einheit möchte ich jetzt mit
humboldt und einigen anderen klassischen
deutschen philosophie philosophen
bisschen expliziter machen
ich beginne dazu mit ganz unkritisch und
begriff des geistes also in einfachen
anführungsstrichen kante hat sich mit
dem geist erstmal mit dem griff des
geistes in seiner schrift träume eines
geistes befasst
und ich lese mal vor weil ich das hier
treffen finden sagt ich weiß also nicht
ob es geister gebe ja was noch mehr ist
ich weiß nicht einmal was das wort geist
bedeutet da ich es indessen oft selbst
gebraucht oder andere habe brauchen
hören so muss doch etwas darunter
verstanden werden
das mag nun dieses etwas ein
hirngespinst oder etwas wirklich es sein
um diese versteckte bedeutung aus zu
wickeln
so halte ich meinen schlecht
verstandenen begriff an allerlei fälle
der anwendung und dadurch dass ich
bemerke auf welchen er trifft und welche
mir zuwider ist für hoffe ich dessen
verborgenen sind
verhalten also hier hatte das
hirngespinst und auch das kann natürlich
ein geist zeit und geister kann
natürlich auch gespenster sein und in
diesem sinne befasst ich kann hier mit
dem geist bickel
es gibt noch eine andere stelle der
anthropologin pragmatischer hinsicht die
ja auch keine kritische schrift ist
jetzt also keiner dieser drei kritiken
in diesem abschnitt vom kunstgeschmack
dass er kann folgendes man nimmt das
durch ideen belebenden prinzip des
gemüts geist geschmack ist ein bloßes
regulative beurteilungs vermögen der
form in der verbindung des
mannigfaltigen in der einbildungskraft
geist aber das produktive vermögen der
vernunft ein muster für jene form
apriori der einbildungskraft unter
zulegen geist und geschmack das erste um
ideen zu schaffen der zweite um sie
verdient gesetzt um sie den gesetzen der
produktiven einbildungskraft angemessene
form verschränken und zum ursprünglich
nicht nach amt zu bilden
denn die hier kommt wieder etwas ins
spiel was wir im letzten vortrag und
diskussion des letzten vortrags gehört
hatten dass sie also kant behandelt wie
wir dann auch noch später sehen werden
in seiner kritik der urteilskraft geist
oder das geist im kontext des schnees
und bezeichnet das genie als ein talent
als ein talent und zwar nicht als eine
grundausstattung und weil dieses geniale
bilden nach ideen dieses ursprünglichen
nicht nachahmte bilden eben nicht in der
grundausstattung angelegt ist eignet
sich wie mir scheint auch der geist
nicht für eine kritische betrachtung im
sinne einer kritik der von uns vermögen
etwa wie es in den drei kritiken tut
also kannte hat keine kritik des reinen
geistes oder kritik des geistes
schreiben können wie mir scheint weil
geist etwas ist was ursprünglich kreativ
originell ist und einst als ein talent
nicht jedem menschen gleichermaßen
apriori zukunft es wäre jetzt mal meine
vermutung auch sind die regionalität
richtung gehend also ich mir scheint er
hat keinen kritischen begriff des
geistes so viel zu kant nur ganz kurz
jetzt möchte ich auf jacobi eingehen und
erscheint jacoby hat ziemlich treffen
die problematik des geil
es geschrieben und auch die frage
thematisiert wie man überhaupt über
geister reden kann also die bedingungen
der möglichkeit einer jeden rede über
geist und zwar in folgendem zitat ich
lese vor der geist verträgt keine
wissenschaftliche behandlung weil er
nicht buchstabe werden kann er der geist
muss also draußen bleiben vor den toren
seiner wissenschaft wo sie ist darf er
selbst nicht sein
darum buchstabieren wer den geist zu
buchstabieren wähnt zuverlässig immer
etwas anderes wissentlich oder
unwissentlich also den geist zum
gegenstand einer wissenschafts machen
bedeutet den geist und buchstaben zu
machen also letztendlich so eine art von
performativen widerspruch zu beginn also
in dem der gegenstand für gegenständlich
wird in dem geist ver gegenständlich
werden soll wird er eben beschnitten
wird beschränkt und darin verliert er
seine ein spezifikum und das finde ich
als ein sehr hilfreiches zitat natürlich
muss man sich fragen darf denn dabei
bleiben bei diesem wert liegt oder läuft
man nicht gefahr hier einem
nationalistischen geist begriff das wort
zu reden wenn man über den geist nicht
wissenschaftlich reden darf ist dein
geist am ende etwas nicht
wissenschaftlich jetzt heißt das können
wir rational das phänomen des geistes
gar nicht verstehen und ich denke das
ist ein problem bei jacobi also so darf
jedenfalls nicht interpretiert er
schalten weil sonst wir eben gefahr
laufen die ganze sache zu verdunkeln
das geht in die richtung auch bei
anderen zu anderen themen bei jacobi
genauso wie der freiheit wir dürfen ja
nach jacobi auch keine gründe angeben
für unser handeln wenn wir gründe für
unser handeln angeben sind wir nach der
kurve nicht frei freiheit bleibt ein
mysterium und ich glaube genau dieses
selbe problem wind der freiheit das
jakobi hier sich etwas weigert oder
ziert die bestimmenden gründe
anzuerkennen dasselbe problem hat jacobi
auch mit dem geist aber ich glaube er
hat zu recht darauf hingewiesen dass wir
aufpassen müssen wir uns den geist gehen
und dass wir nicht für objektivieren was
jetzt aber nicht heißen darf dass wir
ihn jetzt ein risiko um zu gestehen was
wirklich jenseits jeglicher nationalität
ist
die herausforderung ist die rational
über den geist zu sprechen ist rational
sein anzupeilen ohne ihn dadurch
einzuschränken aber auch ohne nur durch
vermutungen oder gefühle über den geist
treten zu können
jetzt möchte ich kurz auf hegels
wissenschaft des geistes zu sprechen
kommen hegel anders als jacobi wie sie
alle wissen meint eben es gibt eine
wissenschaft des geistes und jede
wissenschaft als wissenschaft muss
wissenschaft des geistes sein
phänomenologie des geistes ein sehr
treffendes zitat die vernunft ist geist
in dem die gewissheit alle realität zu
sein zur wahrheit erhoben und sie sich
selbst in sie sich ihrer selbst als
ihrer welt und der welt als ihrer selbst
bewusst ist also hier wird der
unterschied zwischen vernunft und wählt
überbrückt im sinne dieser selbst
identität und dieses bewusstsein der
selbst identität
das scheint ekel hiergeist zonen und das
führt auf einen weiteren wichtigen punkt
des deutschen wortes geister des
begriffs im philosophischen sinne wie
mir scheint geist meint immer zwei
momente der zwei seiten das moment des
erkennenden also derjenige die jene die
sich intellektuell getätigt und etwas
erkennen will
und auf der anderen seite das was
prinzipiell erkannt werden kann also
neues und 9
diese diese kopplung also geist hat
einerseits der subjekt was auf etwas aus
ist und in diesem auszahlen dieser
intensität durchaus geistig ist zugleich
aber auch das korrelat das was
prinzipiell sich erschließen lässt durch
dieses subjektive ausrichtungen diese
einheit scheint hegel hier
wenn ich ein recht verstehe auch mit
geist zum einen diese korrelation
weiteres zitat aus der enzyklopädie der
philosophischen wissenschaften die tat
alle tätigkeiten des geistes sind nichts
als verschiedene weisen der
zurückführung des äußerlichen zu der
innerlichkeit welche der geist selbst
ist und nur durch diese zurück führung
durch diese idealisierung oder
assimilation des äußerlichen wird und
ist er geist
wichtiger punkt hier ist geist ist
nichts statisches was einfach so
objektiv vorliegt sind geistes der
prozess der prozess des zusammenbringen
von erkennen dem und erkennbaren und
zwar so dass alle äußerlichkeit als
alles was noch jenseits der erkenntnis
liegt in die erkenntnis mit eingehoben
wird und mir scheint dass man das bei
hegel als eine art von als eine art von
reduktionismus lesen kann aber kein
tierischer reduktionismus sondern ein
synthetischer reduktionismus also die
zurückführung im geist die zur
rückführung des äußerlichen des
vermeintlich äußerlichen das
vermeintlich anderen aufs innerliche ist
ein reduktionismus aber kein
reduktionismus der die sache verkürzt
sondern der sie synthetisch werden dass
der sie eben gerade anreichert als ich
würde das einen synthetischen
reduktionismus nennen was er hier
ausdrückt also jede metaebene sozusagen
muss wieder als objekt ebene gefasst
werden kann alles äußerliche jede höhere
reflexion muss als reflexion der
ursprünglichen basis verstanden denn
alles muss mit integriert werden diese
integrative dieser integrative begriff
des geistes letztes zitat von hegel noch
mal dazu aus der wissenschaft der logik
nun zitat die wirkliche freiheit ist
also nicht etwas unmittelbar im geistes
sein dass er etwas durch seine tätigkeit
hervorzubringen das so als den
hervorbringen seine freiheit haben wir
in der wissenschaft ist geist den geist
zu betrachten die ganze entwicklung des
begriffs des geistes stellt nur dass
sich freimachen des geistes von allem
seinen begriffe nicht entsprechen den
formen seines daseins da eine befreiung
welche dadurch zustande kommt dass diese
form zu einer dem begriffe des geistes
vollkommen angemessen wirklichkeit
umgebildet werden also hier das
transformative des geistes wie ich schon
sagte kein objekt dass es keiner blickt
das geistig ist
prozess eine tätigkeit und zwar eine
tätigkeit der freiheit indem das größte
das vermeintlich fremde das zu
erkennende in die sphäre des erkannten
aufgenommen und zurückgenommen wird das
nur ganz kurz zu hegel als vorlauf- und
jetzt möchte ich zum eigentlichen punkt
kam nämlich humboldt und ich nenne das
die disziplinierung des geistes warum
humboldts begriff des geistes recht
unbekannt also hat es nach einer schrift
hat einen thematisiert den geist begriff
der die recht kurz ist in seiner 1797
erschienenen schrift über den geist der
menschheit und diese schrift ist wie
vieles bei humboldt nur fragmente
geblieben
in der werkausgabe umfasst dieses
fragment nur 13 zeiten da hat sich der
30-jährige humboldt wie wohl an keiner
anderen stelle in seinen umfangreichen
wirken des geistes befasst humboldts
absicht besteht in diesem text darin
zitat eine theorie der bildung des
menschen zu entwickeln um den
mannigfaltigen arten der tätigkeit
welche der mensch zu üben gelernt hat
ihren wahren wert zu bestimmen wie in
einem brief an christian gottfried
körner bereits geschrieben hatte nichts
geringeres setzt er sich darin vor als
eine schrift über die letzte bestimmung
des menschen und in großem stil im
denken dichten und handeln zu verfassen
und jetzt gibt humboldt in diesem
segment acht charakteristika des geistes
die wie ich finde sehr treffend sind
verschiedene bedeutung des geisel die
ich jetzt hier wiedergeben möchte er
sagt in beiden rücksichten nämlich wesen
und kraft sinnlicher und sinnlicher
natur das ist also wind aber auch
neumann neumann sieht schien geist unter
allen wörtern der man sich hätte
bedienen können das schädlichste erstens
weil es ursprünglich von etwas
sinnlichen dem verstärken bereits
verstärkern reizen der getränke durch
die absonderung der westen teile
weingeist her genommen ist zweitens weil
es streng genommen nie es sei denn mit
einem besonderen zusatz dass rein
unziemliche bezeichnet man sagt richtige
seele und körper als geist und körper
und sehr häufig
der geist drittens weil es gerade das
eigentümliche wort für dasjenige uns
sinnliche ist den wir gerade noch genug
körperliches einräumen um erscheinen zu
können
das synonym von gespenst die seelen der
verstorbenen wandeln als geister umher
wird der punkt weil es selbst in dieser
bedeutung mehr realität hat etwas
kräftigeres und stärkeres anzeigt als
das sonst gleich bedeutende gespenst
so drückt es eine tiefer liegende
verwirrung aus wenn man sagt er sieht
geister als es sieht gespenster fünfter
punkt weil es im psychologischen
gebrauch nie auf das was bloß mechanisch
ist angewandt wird man sagt wie ein
geistreicher immer einen sinn reicher
mechaniker nie ein geistreicher immer
ein sehr reicher versuch
ebenso ist auch spirituell und ingenieur
verschiebt 6 weil es immer die ganze
beschaffenheit einer sache erwiesen
nicht eine einzelne bestimmung andeutet
und daher nie von demjenigen gebraucht
wird was durch eine einzelne kraft
äußerung hervorkommt wenigstens nicht
insofern als man dies zugleich ausdruck
man sagt mir eine geistreiche immer eine
sinnreiche erfindung selbst wenn das
erfundene wirklich geistreich wäre doch
liegt in dieser einschränkung offenbar
etwas willkürliches zither punkt bei
geistreich und geistvoll immer nur da
gebraucht werden wo tiefe der rhein
intellektuellen kräfte mit lebendigkeit
der sinnlichen einbildungskraft
hervorkommen zusammen kommt man sagt
immer nur um eigentlich ein geistvoller
metaphysiker mathematischer logik und 8
und schließlich endlich bei geist
zugleich das herrschende eigentümliche
und echte wiesn im gegensatz des
buchstabens anzeigt hier im punkt 7
sieht man noch das humboldt wie ich
finde sehr zu recht auf die lebendigkeit
zu sprechen kommt also das geistige
zeigen sich dadurch gegenüber der
vernunft aus dass hier das leben eine
rolle spielt das vitale der witz das
gewitzte vielleicht auch in einer
gewissen weise das unverfügbare wie man
beim jeans
und dass dieses leben dieses lebendigen
das scheint mir der grund dafür zu sein
dass kant keine kritik des geistes
machen konnte weil sich ihm das leben
begrifflich entzogen hat also diese
dieses vitalis tische moment des geistes
entzieht sich einer kritik des geistes
das wäre jetzt mal meine these oder kann
man nachher darüber diskutieren
haltepunkt bei humboldt eben wie man
häufig eben sagt der geist versus der
buchstabe der geist ist das eigentliche
wiesen im gegensatz zu den akzidenz
allen eigenschaften finde ich ganz
bedenkenswert diese acht ab so tisch
aufgezählten charakteristika die sich
geben natürlich keine vollständige
beschreibung des begriffs wieder aber
ich für die sensoren nachdenkens wird
und sagt jetzt auch noch mal was hier
zum deutschen begriff des geistes also
zum deutsche wort geist er sagt im
deutschen allein ist der begriff der
kraft des echten wesens herrschen
geblieben ganz ursprünglich nämlich
rühren alle diese wörter von dem begriff
des hauses des windes hier ist davon und
erst als metapher etwas und ähnliches
sind sie auf das verfahren der
destillation als nämlich das ausziehen
des weniger materiellen über getragen
indes hat die psychologische bedeutung
wiederum bald mehr bald weniger von
dieser zweiter metapher an sich gerissen
am meisten offenbar im französischen im
deutschen ist die uhr anfängliche
bedeutung sehr herrschen geblieben und
die zweite metapher zeigt sich nur in
einigen redensarten wie den geist aus
einer sache ziehen und so fort selbst
die uhr anfängliche bedeutung scheint
sehr stark gewesen zu sein und diese
stärke hat sich besser enthalten weil
die wurzel von geist selbst deutsch also
durch ton und eigentümlichkeit uns näher
ist dahingegen spirito esprit und spirit
von spiritus und dies von träumer
herkommt und wie das spiritus noch bei
den alten philosophisch gebraucht wurden
also humboldt argumentiert dafür dass
das deutsche wort geist durchaus gezeigt
ist weil es noch diese ursprünglichkeit
bewahrt
jetzt möchte ich ganz zum schluss noch
auf ein paar verwendung des geistes bei
humboldt eingehen und meine these ist
die dass der geist begriff eine ganz
zentrale bedeutung einnimmt wenn es um
die sprachtheorie geht und wenn es um
die theorie der geschichte geht bei
humboldt in seiner schrift wird die
verschiedenheit des menschlichen sprache
sind ihren einfluss auf die geistige
entwicklung des menschengeschlechts von
18 36 schreibt humboldt ich zitiere die
intellektualität und die sprache
gestatten und befördern nur einander
gegenseitig zu sagen die formen
die sprache ist gleichsam die äußerliche
erscheinung des geistes der völker ihre
sprache ist der geist und ihr geist ihre
sprache man kann sich beiden identisch
genug denke also hier können wir
durchaus sagen objektiver geist was
hegel als objektiven geist denkt geist
ist die manifestation eines
charakteristikum und die sprache und der
geist sind wie er sagt hier fast schon
untrennbar voneinander
ein weiteres wichtiges zitat ist stammt
aus der schrift über die verschiedenheit
der mit des menschlichen sprache aus und
ihren einfluss auf die geistige wesen
des geschlechts den 18 36 gesagt er
folgendes zitat die sprache in ihrem
wirklichen wesen aufgefasst etwas
beständig und in jedem augenblick
vorübergehendes selbst ihre erhaltung
durch die schrift ist immer nur eine
unvollständige mumien artige
aufbewahrung die es doch erst wieder
bedarf dass man dabei den lebendig
lebendigen vortrag zu versöhnlichen
sucht sie selbst ist kein werk ergänzt
eine tätigkeit in ärger ja ihre ware
definition kann daher nur eine
genetische sein
sie ist nämlich die sich ewig
wiederholende arbeit des geistes den
artikulierten laut zum ausdruck des
gedanken fähig zu machen hier wieder wie
schon bei hegel und auch bei jacobi eine
tendenz die objektivierung des geistes
zu kritisieren also geist ist mit
aristotelische begrifflichkeit das am
werk seien die energie ja und sie
wiederholt sich
ist eine arbeit des geistes also das
fand ich eine sehr schöne wendung der
arbeit des geistes eine genetische und
in dieser energija steckt natürlich auch
wieder diese lebendigkeit drin es sagt
dass hier der lebendige vortrag also
hier kommen diese ganzen charakteristika
die wir schon bei kant gefunden hatten
wieder vor und die manifestation die
objektivierung oder das eben geist ein
objekt ist aber geist objektiviert sich
eben immer wieder und zwar nicht einmal
und dann ist schluss sind immer wieder
am werk seien es hat also etwas
permanentes das ist noch hier ein
mediator dann ganz zum schluss noch in
seiner schrift von 1827 über den dual is
hier zeigt wie wir gleich sehen werden
humboldt das geistigkeit immer inter
subjektivität impliziert geist ist
nichts individuelles subjektives zum
immer etwas kommunikatives dialogisches
er sagt ich zitiere in dem unsichtbaren
organismus des geistes den gesetzen des
denkens der klassifikation seiner
kategorien aber wurzel der begriff der
zweiheit noch eine viel tiefere
ursprüngliche weise in dem satz und
gegensatz dem setzen und aufheben dem
sein und nichtsein dem ich unter wählern
besonders entscheidend für die sprache
ist es dass die zweiheit in ihr eine
wichtige stelle als irgendwo sonst
wichtigerer stelle als irgendwo sonst
ein
alle sprechen ruht auf der wechsel rede
in der auch unter mehreren der redende
die alge redeten immer sich als einheit
gegenüber stellt der mensch spricht
sogar in gedanken nur mit einem anderen
oder mit sich wie mit einem anderen und
zieht danach die kreise seiner geistigen
verwandtschaft sondern die wie er reden
denn von den anders reden ab also hier
geistige verwandtschaft reden es immer
wechsel rede selbst wenn man selbst
redet geistigkeit hat immer diese inter
subjektivität und diese dialoge zieht
ist ganz wichtig schließlich noch mit
blick auf seine geschichtsphilosophie
ist wichtig zu betonen dass der begriff
des geistes bei humboldt im gegensatz zu
dem bei hegel nichts theologisches
das ist also ganz entscheidender punkt
geist kommt nicht wie bei hegel zu einem
ende absoluten geist oder erzielt nicht
intentional auf irgendwas hin auf einen
fluchtpunkt ein endpunkt sondern wie
schon der begriff den ärger ja gezeigt
hatte in einem der vorherigen zitate bei
humboldt ist geistigkeit immer etwas was
am werk ist und dass fortbesteht ohne
auf etwas hin zu laufen ich lese mir vor
aus dieser schrift über die aufgabe des
geschichtsschreiber es von 1821 zitat
diese suche nach and ruhe sachen man mag
sie auch aus dem wesen des menschen und
der natur selbst ableiten wollen stört
und verfälscht alles alle freie ansicht
des eigentümlichen wilkens der kräfte
die teleologische geschichte erreicht
auch darum niemals die lebendige
wahrheit der welt schicksale weil das
individuum seinen gips punkt immer
innerhalb der spanne seines flüchtigen
da seins finden muss und sie daher den
letzten zweck der ereignisse nicht
eigentlich in das lebendige setzen kann
sind es in gewissermaßen toten
einrichtungen und den begriff eines
idealen ganze sucht also humboldt
konzentriert sich bei seiner bestimmung
des geistes nie auf dieses kollektiv
sind immer auf das individuum
es geht also um das leben des
individuums ein flüchtiges zahl seien
innerhalb dessen sich der geist
objektiviert natürlich auch im kollektiv
aber nie aus dieser überschau wie es bei
hegel der fall ist auch dass die ganze
welt hierzu läuft also haben wollte hat
hier in wesentlichen mehreren eine
nähere perspektive auf das wirken als es
dieses jahr globale perspektive hegels
tut also geistes nicht theologisch ja
jetzt bin ich am ende schon angekommen
ich möchte jetzt abschließend ein paar
punkte hervorheben die mir im ausgang
von humboldt zentral zu sein scheinen
bei jeder rede über den geist also
geistes nach humboldt und wie mir
scheint auch in der jetzigen verwendung
weise sprachlich geschichtlich und inter
subjektiv realisiert als geistiges
manifestiert sich als prinzipiell
versteht bares diese weise geistiges
oder der geist ist verständlich ohne
notwendigerweise theologisch verfasst zu
sein
geistiges oder der geist ist sowohl
allgemein und objektiv als auch
individuell und subjektiv damit meine
ich eben dieses charakteristikum dass
gesellschaften dass die stadt münchen
einen geist haben kann
genius loci dass man von charakteristika
sprechen kann die kulturell generellen
status haben als auch von menschen die
gewitzt sind die geistreich sind geist
ist eine energetische vollzog
menschliche freiheit das ist ein prozess
man müsste ja noch das leben mit
hinzunehmen also ein lebendiger vollzug
der freiheit und wie mir scheint auch
noch die bedingung der möglichkeit von
sinn also mir scheint dass humboldt in
seinen schriften eine transzendentale
theorie des geistes entwickelt hat so
dass geist letztendlich die grundlage
ist die basis ist auf der überhaupt sinn
auftreten kann
die trans zentrale theorie das ist also
meine these
und das ist jetzt auch das ende meines
vortrags ich möchte noch am schluss
darauf hinweisen auch die beiträge
dieser tagung sollen sofern sie damit
einverstanden sind dieser neuen alberei
geist und geisteswissenschaft erscheinen
und als erster band erscheint jetzt
demnächst im september ein band mit dem
titel die aktualität des geistes und
hier geht es eben um die geister riff im
ausgang von kant bei kant schelle hegel
und so weiter bis zur tarnung auf wollte
sie nun nach hinweisen
vielen dank für die aufmerksamkeit